the England rugby team training through
punishing temperatures in Italy
using the uncomfortable conditions to
better prepare for the World Cup
it's a different pace at this beach
outside Athens but the same Relentless
Sunshine most of southern Europe now in
the grip of a heat wave we've got really
dangerously high temperatures in parts
of the Mediterranean extremely extremely
high and we're also seeing very high
temperatures in parts of Europe that
don't really often deal with high
temperatures at all
it's very early in the season we would
expect temperatures to increase as we go
further through the year and higher
temperatures are associated not just
with impacts on people and
infrastructure but also on increased
risk of wildfires the dark red on this
weather map is a warning of what's ahead
with temperatures set to reach 41
degrees in the south of Spain and Italy
that's six degrees above normal for this
time of year
average temperatures in Europe driven by
climate change have risen over two
degrees compared to the second half of
the 19th century that's twice the global
rate this sort of pressure pattern is
increasing in likelihood because of
climate change we also know that there's
an increase in intensity frequency and
duration of extremely heat events across
Europe we could see temperatures
reaching the late 40s across Italy Spain
and Portugal in the coming days
in Greece it's so hot this week that
working and opening hours might be
changed to cope
here in Athens they are well used to the
heat but taking this weather event very
seriously
urging residents and visitors to stay
indoors if possible and opening cooling
centers for those who don't have air
conditioning
and all this just as summer holidays
begin
earlier in July the world recorded its
hottest week ever
scientists say it's the shape of things
to come Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in
Athens